if i told you
folks in my audience
donald trump called a wisconsin official
to try to overturn the election results
that would not be the most surprising
headline right you would say well we
know he called georgia and we know he
was doing funny business with arizona
it's not really surprising that he
called wisconsin as well sure
what is surprising is trump called the
wisconsin official last week to try to
overturn the results this is not a
repeat it's july of 2022 the election
was in november of 2020. donald trump
called the wisconsin official last week
to continue trying to overturn the
election and when the official was not
into trump's requests he went on truth
say
truth central truth social he went on
truth social
and started calling the guy a rhino all
right so let's look at this this is
assembly speaker robin vos who was
interviewed and says
trump called me last week
to try to
overturn and change the results in
wisconsin
look at this
when's the last time you talked to the
former president president trump uh
within last week in the last week yeah
before after he tweeted about that
before what was that conversation like
you know it's one of those that it's
very consistent he makes his case which
i respect um he would like us to do
something different in wisconsin i
explained that it's not allowed under
the constitution he has a different
opinion then he put the tweet out so
listen to that listen he calls me he
tells me what he wants me to do which i
respect and then i explain to him it's
unconstitutional
why would you respect
trump
trying to strong-arm you into doing
something that's unconstitutional that
that's not worthy of respect and i guess
robin vos is you know trying to mince
words here a little bit what is to be
respected about a former president
demanding unconstitutional action and
case in point i believe robin vos told
trump on the phone yeah we can't do that
because then trump took to truth social
and attacked robin vos saying quote
looks like speaker robin vos a long time
professional rhino always looking to
guard his flank will be doing nothing
about the amazing wisconsin supreme
court decision stating loud and clear
that the impossible to control ballot
unlock boxes in the state are illegal
what a waste of a brilliant and
courageous decision by wisconsin's
highest court the democrats would like
to sincerely thank robin and all of his
fellow rhinos for letting them get away
with murder
a rigged and stolen election now i want
to remind people in the audience who may
have forgotten or maybe you don't know
there is no such thing as
decertification
donald trump's goal
is or donald trump's belief maybe
is that if there is a court ruling that
says oh these ballot boxes were
improperly used that you can decertify
the election now first of all you can't
because those very boxes had a mix of
biden and trump ballots in them and
there is absolutely no way to even
demonstrate that those specific boxes
favored one candidate or heard another
but we're already in beyond fantasy
because there's no such process as
decertification stephen bannon has been
talking about this for a year
he'll casually say on his show
oh yeah we're moving to decertify
arizona oh wow that geez that sounds
pretty serious there is no such process
as the certification like what does
trump think will happen a state will say
we decertify biden as the winner
and then biden's kicked out of the white
house and trump is ushered in like there
is no such process the election ended
uh 20 months ago biden was sworn in
18 months ago and there are very few
ways in which biden leaves early and in
none of those situations does trump
become the president if joe biden dies
kamala harris becomes president they
don't go back and say sir trump come
back doesn't happen number two joe biden
resigns kamala harris becomes president
not donald trump number three congress
uh impeaches and convicts joe biden
forcing him out of office kamala becomes
president not donald trump 25th
amendment is used if the cabinet
believes the president cannot carry out
their duties they can invoke the 25th
amendment biden's removed kamala harris
becomes president of the united states
not donald trump so there is no such
problem think about the layers
there's no evidence that a
desertification should take place in any
state
even if there was evidence there is no
process for decertification doesn't
exist
and even if
you were able to through a process that
exists like resignation
impeachment death of a president 25th a
minute remove the president
it doesn't go to donald trump it goes to
the vice president so it is three or
four layers removed from reality last
week
trump tried to get the wisconsin results
overturned
it's crazy check out the clip on our
instagram which you can find at david
pakman show
one of our sponsors is better help the
customized online therapy service that
offers video phone and live chat with
your therapist you don't even have to
see anyone on camera if you don't want
to you fill out a questionnaire to help
assess your specific needs and then
you're matched with a licensed therapist
in under 48 hours you can schedule
secure video and phone sessions you can
exchange unlimited messages with your
therapist and you can request a new
therapist at any time for any reason at
no charge talking to a therapist doesn't
mean there's something wrong with you it
means you're doing something for
yourself and for your wellness you get
your car serviced you work out you see
the doctor to prevent physical illness
and disease
therapy is the same thing anyone can
benefit from it i think it's very
important join the two million plus
people who have taken charge of their
mental health with better help get 10
percent off your first month at
betterhelp.com pacman the link is down
below